hello everybody and welcome to the 6th
matplotlib video and our little
matplotlib mini series for python 3
where we left off we were showing bar
charts scatter plots and all that and
we've covered quite a few other things
with matplotlib now what I want to cover
is reading data from a file into
matplotlib basically to plot it because
that's really what we want to do at the
end of the day usually is plot from a
file of some source so a lot of people
download CSV s or they have it in a text
file which can be in theory as CSV and
so on so what we're going to do is we're
going to plot from a CSV file I actually
have an example file here that we'll be
using one is just example file dot txt
one is example file dot CSV
put both of these up online you can just
go to the sample code and get them but
the very basic files there's not much to
them I've just basically stored them
like this so on the left hand side here
you've got X values on the right hand
side you've got Y values so if you want
go ahead and pause the video and make
one of these for yourself you don't have
to make the exact same one as I have
just make sure they're comma separated
new lines different X and Y's and then
make sure you don't have an extra little
newline here but even then it probably
won't matter
but anyway closing out of this
minimizing this this was our original
code from before we don't want this
anymore we're going to go ahead we can
leave epic chart in our labels because
we're still making an epic chart that's
for sure but just delete the rest so
we'll keep styles here we'll keep the
labels and stuff and we'll keep the show
but the rest is done so how do we load
in a CSV file so obviously there's a lot
of ways that we can load a csv file we
can use um open and open the csv split
by new line then split by comma we could
use the csv module with import CSV and
use some CSV stuff that I've shown you
guys how to use but in my opinion the
best thing to do is to learn how to open
it with numpy so if you installed the
required modules like I suggested you
have numpy so import numpy as NP if you
don't have known
GoGet numpy anyway so getting up high
style that use will keep the a bubble
law so we're now we're ready to use
numpy to load and use this numpy
function called load text
it's called load text but you can load
CSV files and stuff like that it's not
like you have to load a dot txt file
okay so we're also going to use some
unpacking here so I'm going to say X
comma y equals and if you remember I was
showing you guys unpacking before when
we cover tuples and what it's going to
do is unpack values that are that we're
going to specify how they're separated
here in a minute and it's going to
unpack the values to into x and y for us
so XY equals NP load text NP for numpy
load text is a function within the numpy
then here we specify the parameters of
this load text function first parameter
is going to be the file name well I have
mine called example file txt then comma
we want to unpack because I just said
we're trying to unpack these values in x
and y otherwise it will unpack the
entire data set into one value and it
will actually unpack as a list of lists
so to speak so we've got example the
text and then unpack needs to equal true
and then finally you specify a delimiter
of the file and in our case it's a comma
in many people's cases it might be a
colon a double colon it might be a tab a
space coups
a murder can't type space character and
so on but in our case it's a comma so at
this point we've unpacked the values of
x and y from our file and in fact um you
don't have to follow me here I'm just
going to show you guys real quick print
X print Y learn to tie
and you can see here that we've unpacked
the values one to the rezoning
all the way to 16 in the values of what
now you might be asking well say
Harrison that looks a little funky that
doesn't look like a typical list that's
because it's not when you unpack like
this you basically unpack this into a
numpy array Harrison you said there
weren't arrays in Python well there are
if you use numpy if you use Python
actually everything as a list or a tuple
as opposed but what you would think is
you would call an array is actually just
a Python list but when you use numpy you
can use arrays and this gets very
confusing later on because the things
you thought you could do with a Python
list you try to do with a pot or a numpy
array you can't do it you've got to
convert them out and then convert them
back in and converting out and back in
is something that will actually be
coming quite a bit of soon we're gonna
make sure be covering sockets here in a
little bit and that's going to confuse a
lot of people but anyway you have to
understand that this is a different
datatype than than a typical Python list
anyway moving on we've unpacked into X
and Y's and luckily for us matplotlib
will handle a numpy array no problem and
then later on we can do some numpy
functions on an umpire arrays so it's
really good just to learn how to use
none pi because later on you're probably
going to be wanting it so you might as
well use none pi it for all that you can
another great module to use to load in
files is pandas I'm not sure I don't
think pandas actually works on Python 3
yet last time I tried I couldn't get it
to work I have an entire series on
pandas I just don't think I want to
release it just simply because it's
implied lines you said but I think I
probably will release it but that's
beside the point we're not talking about
that right now moving on
so we'll uncomment this stuff here and
now we're ready to use x and y so we can
just show
PLT dot plot XY save and run it and we
can see that we've plotted a from our
file now just to show I did have a copy
of both example fada text and I haven't
had it as a CSV so I just want to show
you guys it works as is through a CSV
file as well just loads pretty much
anything you passed through there
um so close out of that close that back
that's really it um that I wanted to
show you guys as far as basics of
matplotlib I know I've said it a million
times to say it again if you want to
learn a lot more about matplotlib I've
got a very large matplotlib series
that's just dedicated to all the stuff
that you can do with matplotlib because
you can do a whole lot of stuff so there
we've got live charting multiple figures
on the same plot there's two ways to do
stuff like that multiple figures on
saying that keep saying that multiple
subplots on the same figure organization
like that 3d charts plotting on like
maps all that stuff there's a whole
bunch of stuff that you can do with
matplotlib so if you're interested in
learning more about that check out that
series
anyway that's conclude this series next
topic we're going to talking about is
either I can't member if it's
sub-process
or thread or no better than threading so
processor socket probably make a
subprocess anyway stay tuned for that if
you guys have any questions or comments
on this video feel free to leave them
below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and it's a nice time